Comenzar, what do you think that means?
Comenzar:
To commence.
To commence. Or?
To start.
Again this exists and you can use it and it’s probably easier because it sounds like commence so it’s easier to remember.
But there’s another verb which is more common, which is empezar.
Empezar
This is a z so that’s going to sound /th/ in Spain,
empe/th/ar in most of Spain.
Empezar.
Practice with this one for now.
This is to start.
How do you say I start?
Empezo.
Good, that's what it should be, but what might happen?
Empiezo.
He starts:
Empieze.
What must you do before you make that decision?
What must you do?
You must go back to the “to" form.
It's a very important habit.
It’s empezar.
Empeza.
Good.
And then what might be the next step after empeza?
Empieza.
So this is the process we want to take.
It's essential for us to get into that habit of going back to the “to" form and then we know where we are.
Otherwise it's guesswork.
Empieza: empezar-empieza. They start:
Empiezan.
Empiezan. Good.
You (informal):
Empiezas.
Good.
When are you starting?:
¿Cuándo empiezas?
¿Cuándo empiezas? Very good.
So the E can split to IE.
That's something we need to know about the present and it's something we need to be on top of.
Now it's in the present that this happens because as we know
One of the fundamental elements of the present tense is to have that accent on the penultimate syllable.
So it's having that accent on the penultimate syllable that makes that e vulnerable to splitting.
The e might split to ie, or the o might split to ue.
We know this already actually because we have puedo, and this is a split o.
To be able, or "to can", of course there is no "to can" in English,
to be able we say is poder.
Here actually you can see closer that connection with power.
Before, I said that the word is related to the word power in English.
El poder
el is the masculine the
we also saw it's the word for he,
it's also the word for the for masculine words.
El poder is the power.
So here it's a noun.
It looks like a verb, but if it has the in front of it, we know it's a noun.
El poder - the power.
Poder - to be able.
When you take off your ending and you change it for present tense, and you stress that o, it splits into ue, and you get puedo.
Again we can see the same phenomenon happening between words in English and Spanish.
So, for example, we have the word port in English, but we say Puerto Rico.
Puerto Rico means "the rich port". Rico means rich or nice or tasty or sweet.
So port becomes puerto. We see the o splitting into ue.
We have the word force in English,
in Spanish this is fuerza.
We have the word school,
in Spanish this is escuela.
We have corp in like corporate, which means body.
If Corp means body in corporate,
how do you think it is in Spanish?
Cuerpo.
Good.
We have innovative, and this nov in innovative means new.
When you do something innovative, you do something new.
And the word for new in Spanish is nuevo.
So you saw the o splitting there.
You might have heard pueblo before.
Pueblo means a village or a people.
Population
in Spanish is one of these exceptions.
It's not populación, it's población.
And you can see the connection between
población and pueblo, which means village or people. A people.
You can see the o in pob- splitting into ue in pueblo.
Mortgage, by the way, actually means "death pact".
You have mort-, which is the Latin root for death, and -gage, which means pact. The word for dead in Spanish is - have a guess.
Muerto or muerte.
Well actually, here, one you have the noun, la muerte is the death.
So the noun is the word you put the in front of.
In school they tell you that it's the thing, the object. But this is not an object.
We would think of it, we put the in front of it, it's a noun. La muerte.
But then the adjective, which is describing, it's muerto or muerta. Or muertos or muertas.
So you can see in those words between English and Spanish this phenomenon of this o splitting into ue when it takes the stress.
So this is useful for us for present tense.
We need to know this for present tense
because if we have a verb like dormir, for example, that has an o in the root, when we stress it, it might split.
What do you think dormir means?
Staying still or dormant?
Yeah, what does dormant mean? A dormant volcano.
It actually means it's a sleeping volcano. Or dormitory, this is a nice connection to make as well.
So dormir means to sleep.
How do you say I sleep?
Duermo.
Good.
In Spanish if you want to say I fall asleep, you can say I sleep myself.
So how would that sound?
Me duermo.
Me duermo. Which means I fall asleep, rather than duermo, I sleep.
So you can say I'm falling asleep, me duermo.
It's so boring, me duermo.
He sleeps:
Duerme.
Good.
They sleep:
Duermen.
What do you think encontrar means?
Encontrar:
To encounter.
Good. Which probably means:
To meet.
Oh it does, it means that as well,
but there's a more usual meaning as well.
To find?
Yes.
So I'm finding it or I find it,
how would you say that?
Lo,
is it encuentro?
Yes it is.
Lo encuentro.
Good.
Something useful to bear in mind is that different versions of the verb,
either the “to" form or some other version, might be the noun. So you mustn’t assume always that it's a verb. If you see un encuentro
an encounter
this is now a noun.
An encounter.
Whatever we can put a or the in front of is a noun.
So, many times some version of the verb will be the noun.
Un encuentro is an encounter but encuentro, I encounter.
Demostrar was to demonstrate, and if we get rid of this de-,
we get mostrar which means to show.
Mostrar.
So how would you say: I show?
Mostro.
It would be mostro-
Muestro?
Muestro.
Good.
He shows:
Muestre, wait. Mostrar. Muestra.
Good. Muestra.
We don't need to roll the r here because it's just one r.
Muestra.
Good.
And una muestra actually is a sample.
So there is a noun there that shares that version.
Muestra: he shows, it shows, she shows, you (formal) show.
But una muestra is a sample.
They show:
Muestran.
Muestran. Good.